♪ [upbeat music playing]
HistoryPin essentially
allows you to take old photos
and pin them onto a modern day
street view to make a comparison--
essentially a time machine--
so that you can compare
between what was there before
and what is there now.
Kodak estimates there are billions
of photos sitting under people's beds
that are never shown.
And essentially, they're going to disappear--
the photos, along with the stories
that go with them.
They're essentially going to be gone.
So, the idea was to take all
of these photos and stories
and put them on the web
and allow anybody to see them.
So, using Google Maps technology,
it's a great kind of way
to navigate all of these things.
All of the APIs and the documented
information is fantastic.
And it really makes it easy.
Well, you can expect an app very soon.
So you'll be able to go to a place,
look at the old photo,
and hold up your phone
and see what it looks like now
and what it looks like then.
And it'll show you all the
photos around you as well.
We're also introducing tours
to both the website and to the app.
So, you'll actually be able to walk
from one photo to the next.
00:01:19.208,00:00:00.000